supongamos que estás desarrollando un
producto para hombres el producto está
relacionado con la estatura y se va a
desarrollar en estados unidos por lo que
idealmente te gustaría saber la estatura
media de los hombres en los eeuu déjame
escribir esto estatura media estatura
media de hombres
eeuu en los eeuu así que como hacemos
esto considerando que cuando hablo de la
media estoy hablando de la media
aritmética si estuviera hablando de
otras medias como la media geométrica
entonces tendría que especificarlo pero
cuando se menciona solamente media se
sabe que es la media aritmética así que
cómo le hacemos para encontrar la
estatura media de los hombres en los
eeuu bien la salida obvia es de pregunta
o toma la estatura de todos los hombres
en los eeuu suma a todas las estaturas y
divide esa suma entre el número de
hombres que hay en eeuu pero ahora lo
que hay que considerar es si esto es
práctico pues si estamos pensando que
hay en eeuu del orden de 300 millones de
habitantes digamos que la mitad la mitad
son hombres o de género masculino
estaríamos hablando de alrededor de 150
millones de hombres aproximadamente 150
millones de hombres en los eeuu por lo
que si quieres obtener el valor real de
la estatura media de los hombres en eeuu
tendrás que ir a preguntar y no
solamente preguntar tendrás que ir a
medir a 150 millones
hombres y aunque pudieras hacerlo para
cuando termines muchos habrán muerto
mientras que otros habrán nacido de tal
manera que al terminar tus datos serán
obsoletos así que es imposible o
prácticamente imposible tener una imagen
precisa de la estatura de todos los
hombres en eeuu en un momento dado por
lo que consideras bueno si no puedo
medir a todos los hombres en nuestros
unidos lo que puedo hacer es tomar una
muestra tomar una muestra de hombres en
los eeuu y decides hacer un esfuerzo
para que tu muestra sea una muestra
aleatoria no vas a medir a 100 jugadores
de básquetbol en una universidad o los
jugadores de un equipo de voleibol algo
que le diera un sesgo a la estatura no
decides tomar una muestra aleatoria como
por ejemplo tomar a la primera persona
que salga de un centro comercial en una
ciudad que se selecciona al asad o algún
otro procedimiento aleatorio que impida
que haya alguna tendencia dominante o
sesgo hacia la estatura así que tomamos
una muestra tomamos una muestra de la
cual calculamos la media y esperamos que
esa media represente adecuadamente sobre
todo si la muestra fue la toria
esperamos que esa media de la muestra
presente adecuadamente a la media de
toda la población y vas a darte cuenta
que ese es el fundamento de todo el
trabajo estadístico la base de las
técnicas estadísticas es sacar
diferencias a partir de datos que
obtenemos de la muestra en relación a la
población la población pues no podemos
medir directamente a toda la población
supongamos entonces que nuestra muestra
y si lo fueras hacer en realidad yo
recomendaría por lo menos 100 ó 1000
datos aunque después hablaremos de cómo
saber de qué tamaño o qué tan grande
tiene que ser esa muestra para que tenga
validez pero bueno por el momento
supongamos que te da flojera y tomas una
muestra de tan solo 5 hombres
así es que tomas 5 estaturas la primera
es de 6.2 pies la segunda es de 5.5 pies
es 5 pies 6 pulgadas la tercera es de
5.5 puntos 75 5.75 5.75 pies la cuarta
es de 6.3 pies y finalmente registras
una estatura de
5.9 pies ahora si estos son los valores
que muestre hasta qué es lo que obtienes
cuando calculas la media de esta muestra
para esto saquemos la calculadora y
vamos a sumar 6.2 más 5.5 + 5.75 + 6.3 +
5.9 y esto nos da un total de 29 35
dividimos ahora entre el número de datos
que tenemos entre 5 que es el número de
datos que tenemos esto es 29 puntos 65
entre 5 y obtenemos que la media la
muestre 5.93 pies no tenemos entonces
que la media la muestra y esto lo vamos
a notar como una equis con una raya
encima esto es igual a ya se me olvidó
5.93 5.93 pies esta es esta es la media
la media
muestran la media muestra los y que es
el más preciso la media aritmética de la
muestra y cuando hacemos este cálculo
basado en una muestra de alguna manera
queremos hacer diferencia de la
población cuando hacemos este cálculo
para eso le llamamos a esto un
estadístico un estadístico que estamos
obteniendo a partir de la muestra ahora
te podrías preguntar qué notación usamos
para denotar la media y la población ya
sabemos que no es posible medirla pero
aún así necesitamos una anotación para
referirnos a la media de la población
bien si queremos hacer eso usualmente la
media poblacional se denota por la letra
griega new la media poblacional se
denota por la letra griega new así que
uno de los principios de la estadística
es calcular la media de la muestra para
intentar estimar la media de la
población que no se puede conocer y
estos cálculos para toda la población
los cuales en algunas ocasiones puedes
hacerlos aunque en la mayoría de las
veces es imposible hacerlos estos son
llamados parámetros estos son llamados
parámetros así es que lo que vas a
encontrar en el trabajo estadístico es
calcular a partir de la muestra lo que
estamos llamando como estadísticos para
poder estimar parámetros de toda la
población ahora lo último que quiero
hacer es mostrarte la notación que
aparece en los libros de estadística que
es muy matemática quizás un poco tediosa
pero vas a darte cuenta espero al final
de este vídeo que es hacer exactamente
lo mismo que hicimos para la muestra es
decir sumamos los valores y dividimos
entre el número total de valores en este
ejemplo si tuvieras que calcular la
media poblacional tendrías que sumar los
150 millones de datos y dividir la suma
entre 150 millones así que como los
matemáticos denotan una operación como
esa sumar una cierta cantidad de números
y dividirlo entre esa cantidad pensemos
entonces en el cálculo de la media de la
muestra fue el cálculo que hicimos y
vamos a ver cómo lo denotamos para
empezar matemáticamente vamos a denotar
estos datos como este dato este primer
dato por ejemplo lo notaríamos como x
sub 1 el siguiente dato sería x
el siguiente dato sería x sub 3 y así
cuando estoy diciendo x sub1 estoy
diciendo x subíndice 1 x subíndice 2 x
subíndice 13 sería x subíndice 4 y este
acá sería x subíndice 5 si tuviéramos en
estos datos seguiríamos con x sub 16 x
subíndice 7 hasta x subíndice n y ahora
para denotar la suma de estos datos esto
se haría de la siguiente manera déjame
hacerlo voy a hacerlo por acá abajo
vamos a hacerlo acá abajo entonces la
media de la muestra va a ser la suma la
suma de mis valores que estoy notando
como x subíndice y x subíndice y una
manera de ver esto es que la siss los
subíndices van a variar desde el primer
valor que es x subíndice 1 hasta el
tamaño de la muestra que se denota
usualmente por la letra n
en este caso n fue igual a 5 así es que
esto de aquí abajo está indicando
literalmente está indicando que es x
subíndice 1 + x subíndice 2 + x
subíndice 3 así sucesivamente
x subíndice n de nueva cuenta en este
caso n fue igual a 5 ahora ya hemos
terminado terminamos ya calcular la
media la muestra no definitivamente no
si recordamos no tan solo sumamos los
datos sino que también tuvimos que
dividir entre el número de datos es
decir para calcular la media aritmética
hay que dividir la suma de los datos
entre el número de datos que se tiene
dividimos entre n y está notación puede
apantallar t pero en realidad lo que
está diciendo es suma a los datos que se
tienen y divide entre n el número de
datos que se tiene esta letra griega que
tenemos aquí esta letra sigma mayúscula
que tenemos aquí indica la suma de todos
los valores empezando desde igual a 1
hasta igual a n y luego divide entre el
número de datos que se tienen ahora
consideremos como lo de notaríamos pero
en vez de hacerlo para la media de la
muestra lo queremos hacer para la media
de la población así es que ahora
para la media de la población vivo que
ya mencionamos que esto va a notar la
media la población esto va a ser igual
también a la suma la suma de los datos
obtenidos de la población empezando por
el primer valor cuando y igual a 1 pero
ahora queremos tomar todos los valores
de la población lo cual vamos a notarlo
con una n es una n mayúscula quizás
haciendo énfasis en que está en es mayor
que la n que obtuvimos aquí para la
muestra pero aún no hemos terminado
también de nueva cuenta necesitamos
dividir entre el número de valores que
estamos sumando y nuevamente
desarrollando la suma tenemos que esto
es igual a x subíndice 1 más x subíndice
2 más x subíndice 3 más y así
sucesivamente hasta x subíndice en
mayúscula dividido entre n mayúscula
insistimos que encontramos que en
nuestro caso esto es práctico y esto de
acá es impráctico podemos discutir se
tomó un número adecuado de datos pero
esperamos que la media de la muestra que
calculamos es de alguna manera
indicativa de la media de la población